late for lunch the prime minister has a
question for fellow leaders can we take
our clothes off it's so hot
we all have to show we're tougher than
putin he says
we've got to get the bear chested
horseback riding display says canada's
leader justin trudeau we've got to show
them our pecs says the prime minister
they may be mocking the russian leader
but he'd already sent his message ahead
of this summit 14 cruise missile attacks
against the ukrainian capital mr
president was the rocket striker
if he heard the question president biden
wasn't answering but had a second chance
later
mr president do you have a reaction to
the russian missile strikes on the
apartment building in kiev
more and more barbarism he answered
as the war grinds into a fifth month g7
leaders know they must project unity
against that barbarism good messages
that we all made to stay united which
obviously would you
boris johnson and emmanuel macron were
at pains to show they get on even if
they haven't seen eye to eye and
negotiating with vladimir putin this was
another chance for the prime minister to
leave his domestic troubles behind as he
strides the world stage but he's using
the summit to urge other leaders to give
ukrainians what they need to win
the price of allowing putin to uh to
succeed to to to hack off huge parts of
of ukraine to to
to continue with his program of conquest
that price will be far far higher and
everybody here understands that
it's a long way from this picture
postcard setting but ukraine's war and
its consequences overshadow this summit
worsening the chances of recession and
soaring inflation and threatening mass
hunger in the third world another
casualty of war could be g7 efforts to
tackle climate change the german hosts
are reportedly trying to water down
plans to end the financing of overseas
fossil fuel projects as they try and
wean themselves off russian energy
the longer the war goes on the greater
the pressure on these leaders to stand
together and not buckle in the face of
putin's aggression
dominic waghorn sky news bavaria